all right check baby i'm trying to get
wet man
that's one thing and i'm trying to get
wet i notice i'm trying in the summer
i'm trying to get wet
and that was always a key
deal for me as a child you know
we had a fella that lived down the
street from us little fella named boogie
you know and uh he was
mixed man a little black white i mean
his daddy was white and his
they pretended his mom was his mom was
well
his daddy knocked up the woman that
swept out the school bus
his daddy was our bus driver big milford
and he didn't
you know he didn't know a lot of the
letters of the alphabet and you'd
sometime you'd surprise him you'd show
him on a thing you know qrst and
he didn't he just couldn't stand he
don't
he would kind of shut down he just
couldn't handle it
you know he'd never been uh
you know he'd never been educationally
succumbed to
the truth and anyway
but he drove the school bus and he
eventually got laid off for uh
driving shirtless and driving
uh under the influence of alcohol and
running the bu and hitting um
stuff with the bus trees and other stuff
that
you just can't do if you have children
on board you know
and uh anyway but so
what happened he uh he knocked up a lady
that swept out the school bus
and um this was a black woman and he
knocked her up and so they had a child
but they pretended that the child was
with
him and his regular white wife
so it was just
you know it was just a real ferris wheel
of
of sex and secrets and
and school bussery type you know
praise god baby
let's get into it
this is matthew casio runs in the family
[Music]
can't save my soul
it's just a matter of time
and
there you go right there that's matthew
casio runs in the family
and we out here baby i'm out here like a
damn uh
like a dolphin in a damn uh
at a gay spa baby we out here
you know and i want to say shout out to
everybody that's gay and that's being
you know or you know considering being
gay man
you guys are doing great and um
you know and i will comment as well one
time
and i may have shared that one of the
more
one of the more kind of uh homoerotic
type of
atmospheres i've ever seen i saw
a you know a group of gay men throwing a
frisbee
together in a um
hot tub and they were so close together
they couldn't even
you couldn't i mean there wasn't one of
the guy two of the guys was too close
together to even throw it they had
he basically had to like put his arm
straight and then
hand it to the other hand it to the guy
basically
so it was like
and i i i don't know i don't know
honestly what that was about or what i'm
really
saying there but i just and i love
hampton inn man
god i love hampton man i just
you know i love the they redid them
about i want to say 12 years ago
and they put these kind of black and
white pictures on the inside of the
elevator doors that are kind of
welcoming and there's like a child on a
swing or something and
you know there's a little baby eating a
damn egg or something
and it just makes you feel good
and you know hampton inn they got a
they have a concierge breakfast
downstairs
and concierge breakfast is basically i
think it was
i don't know when it started but
the whole thing started with uh
during war times they would somebody had
to get up and make the breakfast of the
colonel and they would make it quick it
would be just kind of
you know so he could dine and then dash
and hit the field
and that was concierge breakfast but uh
i don't know what war it could have been
a lot of wars i i'm sure it wasn't
one war and i don't know why hampton inn
took on a damn
war feat you know
why they adapted some of their feeding
styles from
war seems really
kind of next level to me but
you know god does what he does and um
what else man uh i don't even know what
i'm talking about exactly
i had some family come in town this
weekend we had a nice time
we i went skeet shooting
you know i'm out here in the central
east and we there's not
you know there's a lot of people shoot
stuff
around here and it's not usually
other people you know in big city people
like to shoot kind of other people in
in more rural areas they like to shoot
stuff
and so out here we went to some skeet
shooting
and uh and it was fun man i'd never done
it
[Music]
you know they loaded up a shotgun i'm
out there
um we went out to kid rock's house
actually and he got
i mean he lives in a beautiful trailer
really it's a
it's a trailer like you know like you
see
the style they got you know it's nice
though they have a nice
i think they have two couches in it um
but off the back they have this little
man-made kind of lake
and he had a skeet fire
right off the back and so
we're out there man and uh
and people showed me how to shoot
skeeding next thing you know i'm out
there just elmer fudding on them
mitch yes
and i'm upstairs baby if you want to
know where i'm at on the winner's
bracket
i'm upstairs okay
i'm upstairs
but that was enjoyable what else um
i got some dang azaleas uh
and that's
it's interesting as a man something's
going on with you as a man when you
buy a few azaleas i'm noticing
you know and i don't know what's hap i
mean it's
you know i just i got i just
i bought 14 of them and you know they
just
there's space i have a yard and so i
have to there's got to be something in
it
you can't just have a damn stale yard
and there's
nothing out there and i've thought about
getting two goats but
they don't some of the websites i'm
reading about goats says they're really
loud
so i don't know if i want to deal with
the
noise complaints and having cops come
back there and then they see you know
it's me
and i'm just living by myself and i have
14 azaleas and two goats
i mean damn you know
i don't know if that's kind of the kind
of stuff that i want
uh but yeah that was good man so that's
you know that's what happened this week
i'm trying to think of what else is
going on
not much man i'm just growing up you
know
i've been realizing that i'm growing up
and
honestly sometimes man i'm growing a
little bit lonesome
you know i grow a little bit lonesome
it's like i'm i'm at home sometimes and
there's nobody there
you know and i'm not complaining i'm not
oh
what was me you know like i'm just
thinking about it
you know when it's titty time of year
you know that this is when the calendar
breaks out then boingos baby
them front bags you know what i'm saying
them freaking sternum werthers baby you
know what i'm saying them big caramels
them nippled huskies you feel me
tit time baby this is tit time because
it's summer
so this is when it's a good time to get
out there and meet somebody
so we'll see um
because yeah i start thinking about that
next chapter of my life and what it
would be like
you know and get me a little offspring
and get me a damn
you know get a little bird or something
or get a damn you know
get me a couple living items
so when i come home something yells or
barks or shits or something
you know i started thinking about it
because one thing i realized is the the
pattern that i'm in it just gets it just
gets old after a while it's not
bad but it just kind of
you start looking you know you wonder
what else
is there something else
and it's not to be found i don't think
in like worldly things like in
a vacation or a
you know buy you some speakers for the
car you know get you a couple 22s or
something
you know it's not um it's not the kind
of thing that's
you can solve by getting 14 azaleas
you know and i think it's figuring out
how to be in a relationship and get into
some real love
where i can
you know get a little baby out of
somebody out of some woman's body
and be like that
because it also starts getting weird
when like
all your friends have children that are
old they're getting like
older and you it's like
it gets a lit you're like who's that
there you know you just don't at a
certain point you
there's nobody left there's the
you know there's not as many
people to even call or do as much with
in some ways because everybody's moved
on or
adapted into different realms of life
so you know i think i've been thinking
about that some
and then i started thinking about what
it's going to take for me to get to a
place like that to get to be able to be
you know in a serious relationship where
i'm going to stay in it and be
honest and
you know not be
you know running around or trying to
play close frisbee with some woman that
some strange woman at a hampton inn you
know what i'm saying
because close frisbee is obviously a
gateway drug i feel like possibly to
homosexuality
praise god man and shout out everybody
that's gay i think gay pride is coming
up actually
i saw a woman yesterday she had a
haircut and
she said uh something about gay pride
she said
so yeah july looks like well hell i
don't know uh
march i don't know but
that's something that's going on
something else that's going on i'm
drinking liquid death and you know it's
a great it's a good drink
people think it's a beer you see a child
drinking it outside of a damn 7-eleven
and
you see the cops pull up and tase them
you know and then they go over and it
says water
you know tough kid thank god i want to
tell you this i got tour dates
and uh i'm getting excited i'm working
on some new materials so this is going
to be
this is going to be a joy man it's going
to be starting in st louis
friday september 17th uh that show sold
out and we've added one
uh on the 17th then we go to cincinnati
uh on the 18th um and that looks like
it's sold out we may be adding another
one there
we have charlotte then durham and we
added a new show in durham chattanooga
knoxville tennessee wilmington delaware
wilkes-barre
pa minneapolis minnesota i'm grateful to
be coming back there
and that one sold out so we added a new
one charleston south carolina richmond
virginia baltimore
black maine they call it albany sold out
we added one
buffalo and columbus ohio that's sold
out
and we uh we have added one if not if it
doesn't show added it'll show it this
week
so thank you guys for the support
um you know it's interesting i i i even
just look at the chattanooga date and uh
i remember the night after my you know i
have a comedy special that's out there
on netflix and
after i had done the comedy special my
first shows were in chattanooga
and uh
so i'm excited you know i'm thinking
this is it
we did it you know i'm on netflix and we
did it
and uh and we made it
and i get to the car i get to the venue
and i want to say i've gotten in a night
before i don't remember
but i get over to the venue that day and
uh i did i got in the night four because
i went to radio in the morning
and i got over to the venue and and
there was probably seven people there
and i was like damn
he just you know the comedy especially
just didn't move the needle they didn't
put it in the circulation on the site
and
you know there was some uh
doxxers people that came out that kind
of stuff but
um online but it just didn't do it
and so man that was a tough weekend
because and also the stage was really
high from the audience
so the audience it was like 10 feet down
off the stage and
it almost almost i felt like they were
trapped like i was telling jokes to
people that were
waiting for fire and rescue it was like
you know and then
you know and uh and
uh home upstairs and i literally was
upstairs i mean i was like way high up
compared to these people
at one point i wanted to throw a rope
down i just felt very
obtuse you know what was going on there
and um so anyway
so i'm excited about all those dates
theo vaughn.com tour
you can get tickets because now we're
playing at a theater
and i think we already have sold it out
maybe almost in chattanooga
and so i mean it's just a blessing
you know it's a thousand or something
people or 50 i don't even know what it
is but it's um
man and that's the power of this podcast
man and i want to thank you guys so much
you know uh you know for just for me
give me the opportunity
and i promise i'm going to bring the
best stuff that i can to you and we're
going to enjoy it
you know what i'm saying like four
fellows in a damn hampton it
looks like four frisbee fellas in a
hampton in spa
baby four frisbee fellas in a hampton
inn hot tub
let's go and then one of the guys said
to the other he's like you guys go on
that side
like there's no sides bro
there's no sides in a hampton inn hot
tub cat daddy
praise god man
you know and um
[Music]
and we've all i'm trying to think of
everybody i want to win the first time
you ever ran
you know met someone who was gay or if
you realized maybe if you could have
been that person
you know when i was young there was a
lot of rumored gay
men they didn't have gay women when i
was young i don't think
but they had game in and uh there was
one fella and he had
i don't know if he'd been hit by but i
don't know what happened to him
something happened to him he was born
without a heart or something i don't
know
i don't know what happened to him he had
autism or something
and uh
and his mom he was probably 40 when i
met him
and he he would ride one of those
bicycles that had the child seat on the
back that baby seat
that little scoop and score baby that
little you know
looked like part of a bucket on the back
and that's where the baby would sit
and that man would drive around town
that bike all the time
and somebody said that the baby seat was
a he had a husband
they used to sit back there and like a
little husband
because it was a woman's bike it was
remember moms used to have this bike
where
now the kids in like this little thing
and it's got like these roll bars and
like you know now the kid
whatever you know the kid don't have a
chance of getting hurt but when i was
young you had you sat in the back behind
mom you know just you were in the bite
the ba
the baby said the bite the the uh
you were you know you were downstairs
you know i was saying he was downstairs
he was behind mom just bouncing back
there bird
on you you know didn't even
matter he could be back there smoking
mom had no idea
she could it was impossible for mom to
even see you
so you were just back there you know
and so he was on the front of the
woman's bike in the back was a baby seat
and it had um and people said that the
man had a little husband that had left
him
and so as a child that was just
you know the rumor in our town that this
dude
or this gentleman really or you know
this guy
he uh he'd had a little husband that
left him
and it and it broke his heart or
something and so but really later on i
realized the man was mentally ill
and that he just he been born i want to
say he was born that way also he could
have been hit by a
vehicle but he it was either nature or
nurture
you know and god bless him and but the
rumor was that the man was a gay man
when i was young and so
it's just interesting how you first hear
about
uh gay men or see a first gay man or get
an idea about it
you know it's just really fascinating
how that comes into people's lives uh
that aren't gay i'm sure well even if
you are gay i'm sure you still have a
certain moment where it's like oh this
is
you know this is something that's going
on
so but
anyway what else do we have man um
you know i want to thank you guys yeah i
want to thank you guys for this tour
some place is already selling and i'm
excited about it and
i'm going to grasp onto a name soon we
had a couple of names that came in
and i want to listen to a few more that
came in from from somebody and thank you
uh in advance here we go
hey what's up theo or i mean probably
nick
listen to this but um i know i've called
several times when he's chris man i
lived in uh
houston from uh from baton rouge
but i just wanted to say but i think
it'd be a really cool name for your
special to call it uh
less beyond because i know you drop that
a lot
on your pod and you usually make some
pretty awesome points
uh when after you say that well thanks
chris man i appreciate that's a nice one
then
let's be honest man because you try to
be
you know you try to be honest the battle
to be honest
it's easy but man it's there's some
tempting little tributaries
skirting off the river of truth isn't
there man
some lascivious licorice
liquid
alleyways just leaking off that river of
truth man uh
let's be honest i like that one man i
really like that one
um and let's take one more that came in
one more suggestion
what up deal i just listened to the most
recent episode and i heard
some of the suggestions for your tour
name i was thinking bro
why not to get that hitter tour you know
get that hitter get that sitter come on
out come to the show
oh gang get that hitter get that sitter
now that's a real little vibe right
there that's a real tempting deal what
you're saying bud
that's called a tempting deal when
somebody says something and
and you feel tempted by it that's a
tempting deal
and if you and i were in a hot tub i'd
throw you to frisbee on that one both of
you guys
i thought about the be good tour
yourself but that's kind of too much of
a play on words
i've been thinking about i've also been
waiting for when i'm on stage for
something to strike me
but i like let's be honest i'll like get
that hitter um
and i appreciate him man appreciate you
guys caring enough to even submit a man
i appreciate that
you know a lot of beautiful stuff came
in uh for this episode we'll get into
some of it
um and i'm gonna play this is a video
question that came
in first from someone uh here we go
derek from battleground washington uh
what's up derek from batagarna ah
i never been up there washington is
interesting
because you're over by the coast you get
seattle
you get tacoma
and then after that
it's anybody's ball game you know it's
basically like
i mean it's a lot of people making
homemade furniture out of hemp and uh
and watching animals mate if you go east
or there and
and both of those are you know
legitimate practices
so praise brother onward i say i love
your podcast love what you're doing over
there
and i had a quick question for you uh
some of my family members
doing this thing where they uh take
saunas together
it's usually all grown men they all have
wives
they do they take them nude nude saunas
and uh
you know i'm not really into that kind
of stuff but i just want to get your
thoughts on it
if you'd ever do it or ever heard of it
or thought of doing it
you know but yeah anyways gang gang
gang brother and um you know i'm sorry
your family's going through that and
that you're having a
you know call for
you know help about that and thank you
um you know
going to saunas and doing steams
it's just so ironic this call came in
because of what i was talking about
earlier at that hampton inn
and that's one time some ways
uh gay men are less inhibited
they're almost really the native
americans of our time in some ways
and no offense if anybody's native
american you guys are the original
native americans
but then it goes really almost to
aggressive gay men
because with sunburn because
you they will do a lot of
male stuff that's kind of bonding
and a long time ago if you look on a lot
of hieroglyphs
you know or you know if you look
in you know history books a lot of
native americans would do saunas they
would do steam
huts and get in there and smoke each
they would just be
high as and as many rocks as you
can get in there
and people's just damn just feeling that
warm geology just cook them to the
bone shout out bryce mitchell and you
you just and they would do that together
and they would encourage each other you
know
ronnie or kunta or dang you know uh
wiffle ball or you know sitting river
the different
you know i'm pulling from all different
walks of life here but there
everybody would encourage each other to
stay in there and bear the heat and bear
the
the the pain
and then they would leave you know and
they'd but they'd have gone through
something together
and there's there's there's some real
strong value in that
there's some metamorphosis in a way that
that i don't know if we get anymore we
our souls these days sometimes i feel
like our soul is just
out of the ocean and it's just got stuck
on the beach
especially here in america you know and
i'm obviously you know i'm
i'm talking as a white or semi-white
from a first world country
but and i don't you know and maybe some
of this is just more later in my life as
i've
you know i've come into more opportunity
and a little more wealth later
recently and uh
but yeah i don't know there's something
there's
about being in the ocean about being in
the
storm just being weathered and going
through things
you know um
and then because it does something to
your soul
you know i really feel like it does you
know time when you
take your soul and add time and you add
you know you just add a
you know you need a weather report you
can't just have it just be the beach
you know we're not challenging our we
don't have that
internal challenge
you know we don't have that that
struggle
that's that's on us
you know we don't have that turmoil
that makes us into treasure
or shows us what our we don't we're not
this there's less
revealed to our spirit
when we're in comfort and uh
but yeah i mean it's a little weird if
your family's getting together in an
empty above ground pool and just having
sandwiches and you know and
drinking cold water
i mean that that's probably some of
that stuff honestly
derek could be uh drug induced
and you know i grew up running a lot of
that over there and
over mcgee street over in covington
louisiana they had
about seven houses down from us they had
a uh
above ground pool
and men would meet up and over there at
night or in the daytime when it was cool
out and put some chairs in it and stuff
and they would
do drugs and drink cold water and
like that
and it was almost
you know i'm not gonna say that they got
into homosexuality but they considered
it i'm sure
and probably got into it so it's you
know it's just that kind of you know
it's
it's hit or miss out there with some of
these saunas but
but there's a lot of gay men or they
know they are they spend a lot of male
bonding time
doing stuff like saunas ice baths
and things like that where you are
where it used to be a lot more tribal
where you would show your body
you know and one time you know a buddy
of mine
and he was a you know a nice cool guy
and an urban gentleman and he
you know he had that hawk on him baby he
had that body lumber baby that weiner
and uh he walked in front of a
group of our friends naked to go into
the showers
and i was still like over by like the
kind of the locker area and stuff like
that and so i
i i was like dang well i gotta
i can't walk in like all clothed and
then take my clothes off in the shower
i'm gonna be
such a wimp so i'm like i gotta get
naked here and then walk in front of all
the guys to get over there
you know and just be cool about it and
be casual
but my penis was definitely doing that
punxsutawney feel
you know this thing had seen its shadow
this thing
i don't know what it was doing it was
almost like it had you know it's almost
seemed like i didn't even have a penis
and so i'm literally trying to fl
get my penis at least enough
so when i walk by the guys they don't
look and see i don't have any penis
that's not
you know you can't do that around your
buddies at like an incremental age this
was
this was inc socially incremental
and uh you can't do that
you know i needed to stay on the
staircase moving upward socially you
know i needed to get
upstairs and um
and so i dude i literally was just i
remember i had a wallet i was
kind of trying to whip my wiener against
the side of my wall i was doing anything
to get my body to really enjoy some
blood flow
and finally man i got i don't know i
probably got down
nine thimbles of blood into my wiener
and i just said this is the best i'm
gonna do
and so i had to sk then i scooted in
front of people and i moved pretty fast
and i even think i walked sideways so
they would just see my
my derriere baby that french ass
um but thank you derek for
for sharing that and you know i think
there's two ways to look at it
one is that it could be you know leading
it could be a slippery slope for drug
use or it could be
you know you guys getting real primal
you know the next thing you guys are
doing is burning each other with coals
and doing tattoos on each other
and out there whim hoffing up near each
other's ass cheeks baby praise god
brother
and i love you all right man oh i want
to tell you about this
and you know it and you should know it
man
um that today's episode is brought to
you by
none other than ship station
you know a lot of businesses they don't
they make stuff and they don't know how
to get rid of it
some you'll drive past a business a man
will be out there with a bunch of
slinkies or something
just his hand in the air
and that man's not doing well because he
doesn't know about ship station
if you started your own online store
you're doing what you love
you're selling products that people want
and orders are coming in
now that's the hard part
shipping the products out luckily
shipstation makes that easy
with shipstation it's simple to import
manage and ship your orders out fast
for a lot less money there's a lot of
high dollar places you could go ship it
you know uh what's the one where you it
costs damn sixty dollars to send
somebody forty dollars western unions
than my ship station is the
number one shipping software
import orders from any sales channel
ship with any carrier
and automate just about any shipping
task
no matter if you're selling on amazon
etsy or your own website
shipstation funnels all your orders into
one simple interface
you can access from your computer or
your cell phone
you even get access to amazing discounts
with major carriers including usps
fedex and ups yep just
use our offer code theo to get a 60 day
free trial
yep that's two months of free no hassle
stress free shipping just go to
shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the page and type in t-h-e-o
that's shipstation.com in our offer code
theo
make ship happen you know some
mattresses you get them and they don't
they don't do it for you
every now and then you'll see a mattress
pulled out to the curb some
little orphan some little damn rectangle
rest orphan out there
but what can help is getting you a
mattress that
contours to your body that that holds
you
if you don't have a woman or
somebody to love to hold you at night
helix can help if you can't sleep
because of politics pandemics
or any other drama that's going on out
there
so maybe somebody threw a frisbee too
fast at you at a damn hampton in bath
bath house sleeping on a terrible
mattress
uh-uh not anymore
you gotta upgrade to helix helix sleep
has a quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete and matches your body type and
sleep preferences
to your perfect mattress why would you
buy a mattress made for someone else
that's a great point you ever go get any
of fat daddy's bed and he got
you can't even get out of it remember
that you remember when you was young
you'd go over to some
fellow's house and he had a fat daddy
and no offense anybody but and you get
in their bed you couldn't even damn get
out of it
because things just cave in in the
middle the sides of the mattress hitting
you in the head you can't even you don't
even know where you are
everybody's unique and helix knows that
so you have several different
mattress models to choose from soft
medium and firm
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot
you know i had a fella used to work on a
farm and he used to uh
after it rained he would lay out he
would take his shirt off and lay on the
cement
like a reptile baby take the helix quiz
figure it out and no
take the helix quiz and they'll tell you
what you like how what fits with your
style
and then they can deliver it to you go
to helix
sleep dot com slash theo that's
h-e-l-i-x
s-e-l-e-e-p dot com slash
t-h-e-o take their two-minute sleep quiz
they're offering up to two hundred
dollars off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix
sleep dot com slash theo that's helix
sleep.com for up to 200
off and two free pillows and hey nothing
to help you get a woman or
or a man over there if you love men than
uh an extra pillow
that's a good pick-up line hey you know
i got an extra pillow
so there you go
oh man
what else the world's things are getting
back to busy
you know it's interesting i feel
i'm curious how the next year is going
to be
you know i feel like a lot of the fabric
of our society really
kind of has been really
denigrated over over time over the
pandemic
you know it used to be that you know you
had the week and it meant something in
the month
and the holidays and you know
but now it's i feel like it
tie you know it's all time doesn't mean
as much it's just it's all confusing
still there's all there's still all this
it feels like a rubik's cube out there
you know and you also have talked about
it before but they had a lot of like
you know you had a lot of political and
social
commentary and disruption and unrest and
uh adjustment
and yet a lot of history that some
people said shouldn't be history and
that
you know that kind of stuff affects
places and people and communities
and something you once prided or thought
was a part of your
youth or your childhood or memories and
now when people say it doesn't mean
anything or it's
or that's not realistic
or that doesn't fit with what i think
or they think or you think or whatever
you know
whoever thinks then it adjusts uh
i don't know we just adjust some of the
tapestry
so i'm intrigued man i'm intrigued and
i'm
i'm hopeful though that's all we can be
is hopeful man and that's where i'm
going to stay
and that is the fight that i'm in i
notice for myself is to
stay hopeful
you know because i get angry pretty easy
um so just trying to
say some of that out loud uh
but anyway not to get in a downerness
here's an upper
we got this video came in right here
let's see it
hey theo vaughn what's up gang gang
you asked for your you asked for a
couple wins and
well we just got married so there's a
win
uh this is sarah my wonderful wife
uh and i'm austin we live in chattanooga
tennessee so hey when you come in
october we're gonna
i'm gonna try to see you honestly well
you should bring sarah man this is your
wife
he's not really much of a fan and
she married me so obviously she has bad
taste
but hey congratulations man that's
awesome
austin and sarah that's his wife and
they might be on
i don't know if they're amish but they
they look like out kind of uh
woodworker types you know beautiful
and uh congratulations man that is a
good win baby
feeling that love and making that choice
and you got to base them eggs that you
got to get out there and get that
nuptial rocking
you know you need to play some close
frisbee you feel me get up at that
hampton inn
with your lady and play that gross that
close frisbee with them ovules baby
and get that little bambino son praise
god dude shout out everybody
congratulations austin that is a win we
had some other wins that got sent in man
and
and this is a good time to get into some
of them uh these things make me feel
exciting and and we got to celebrate
these things
you know and we have to do it for
ourselves man i need to celebrate
you know i need to celebrate and be you
know grateful and excited
and excited man you know
because that's what life is just these
little things you know it's the little
things where you feel like you gain some
ground
where you put a stake in the ground for
yourself so
i'm happy to be reminded of that uh
let's hear a couple of a couple wins
that came in right here man
what's up theo this is jarrett from the
great state of texas
what's up big jarrett and jarrett has
always been an interesting name one
if it ends in a t jarrett because jared
you know i get you know you understand
that that's going to be a name
when you're growing up and then they hit
you with jarrett and that's
you know it just doesn't land as well
sometimes but god bless you brother and
i'm happy you're
you're alive and last podcast you wanted
people to call in who were winning who
were getting some dubs i just want to
let you know after
you know i've taken a lot of l's in my
days and i'm still pretty young but
just want to let everybody know i hope
you're winning in my win recently it's
actually this weekend
i'm finally graduating after six years
from the great school called tarleton
state university
with my mechanical engineering degree
there you go baby tarleton
and that fellow graduated from tarleton
and i'm sure they probably have a
quidditch team
over there at tarleton and
and i i you know it's uh congratulations
man i'm glad that you're graduating
i do believe that tarleton
is misspelled
and i don't know if it's supposed to be
something else it was supposed to be
carlton or charleston
or something else something
but the uh but tarleton tarleton isn't
anything but
but that doesn't matter you went there
and you beat him baby you you freaking
beat that bowser dog
and that's what happens and that's what
happened to you so praise baby
congratulations man
let's hear more
what up theo my name's sam i i
listen to the episode about wins and
uh you i just graduated college so i'm
winning right now i'm high on life and
i'm i'm just so excited to be alive i
love what you do love listening to you
and you just said colin was a win and
i'm just i feel like a winner right now
you are one sam congratulations and it
is graduation time
you are one sam you sound like a winner
too and you sound that you sound good
and
and uh and i'm glad you're doing well
you know i remember dude graduating is
so wild
because you're about to go out into the
you know graduating that we you know the
whole life you've been petting the dog
and finally you see
you know graduating is that moment when
you finally look around that back
leg and you see that dog's ass or that
junk
that body junk you know that back jaw
baby
you see what that dog you know you see
or the you know wean or whatever is back
there
and it's just a revealing time because
you're like well now what do i do
where what's remember that remember that
moment
take these glasses off
remember that moment in college man when
you got done with college
and you're like well now wha
there's no more home or there's no more
class there's no more
you know and now it's just you if you're
still living in the college it's just
like you got to make decision where do i
go what do i do
that was always man let's hear a couple
more that came
in uh here we go
hey theo what's up man this is josh
i'm originally from home of louisiana
what's up josh out there in houma
and homa you know that's a good place to
uh
do you wake up and find a damn pearl
under your tongue man that's real a
seafood capital
homer that's really that's a seafood
belt son
you might have to devein your cousin
over there that's the real seafood belt
onward living in lafayette man down here
down the boat
the gutter south like we like to call it
a couple weeks ago man you asked about
putting some wins on the board
i just recently found out that i have
degenerative disc disease
i'm 34 years young uh and it's only
going to get worse
a lot of my feel my discs and my
sacral spine never fully developed so my
l spines being a little
oh gang man i'm sorry about that
man yeah the spine is the real
you know it's that real information
super highway baby that's a space bar
you know and it's a real it's a real
hotbed of information and capability and
i've had part of my disc taken out l5 s1
dude i don't know where they took it
you know and i don't even have the
paperwork still to know the man that did
it
but uh but anyway man i just i feel for
you baby to have that
stem issue you know to really
because you want to stay in the forest
daddy you know cause you get too stemmed
up
or stemmed out you'll be a damn potted
plant brother but praise god baby plants
grow plentiful down there in uh southern
louisiana let's hear more
and uh got a couple herniated couple
bulging
uh but i found a win man i was doing uh
hard labor for a long time my life oil
field retail
uh thankfully man this this
architectural company gave me a shot
brother
so that way i'm able to still work and
not have to be
disabled or anything like that so just
trying to
stay with emotions and stay positive man
so that's that's my win
gang baby i love that man and thank you
for sharing that message with me i i i
needed to hear that
yeah man if they architectural engineer
they might build you a damn new
spine bruh
do not put it past these people
you know you might uh you
you know what i'm saying they could do
it all who knows how capable they are
so i'd love to see you out there with a
damn
that cedar back strap you know
just see you out there with a damn uh
cane pole
uh centerpiece that's what you know
i could see you having that so and i
love the fact that you're not just
giving up man
you're gonna stay in the ring you know
there's a lot to be said for that man
and that is a win baby gang thank you
for sharing that man and i love you bro
and uh and yeah if you could do that man
we could do a lot
you know we could do a lot bro and i
don't mean you and me bro i'm not trying
to
do it i like women but i'm just saying
that you know what i'm saying
it's inspirational man you know
it's inspirational your attitude of not
wanting to give up not wanting to take
the easy way
um because it's hard to do it's hard to
do man
we got one more one more win came in
let's get it
hey theo this is uh this is dan from uh
chicago
um i just wanted to uh
tell you and your listeners um a great
thing i had happen
is that uh my my son i i see him every
weekend and um
it i always wonder if he's you know
thinking about me or not
and uh his mother and i we don't get
along that well
um but yeah like last night he uh
he called me from his mom's phone and uh
it
it absolutely was amazing because
i didn't know like yeah i mean he's only
six
i didn't know if uh when we're not
together if he's
thinking about me or not and uh he
called me just to
see what i was doing and um
it was it was amazing like it uh just
rejuvenated me
um but anyway man uh
i just i wanted to see like if you uh
if you're you know connected to your
nieces and nephews
and uh you know if they just call you to
let you know they're thinking about you
well thanks dan that's a the that that
that
that's a great uh win right there man i
can imagine that and
and i i just appreciate you sharing this
moment because
yeah you know you don't think about that
as um
i it's i appreciate you sharing that
because yeah you wonder
or i could imagine wondering yeah does
my kid think about me like
you know obviously you think about him
that's the child
and that's your job and that's your
instinct
but does he yeah like what is he
and then yeah to have kind of like a
little breakthrough moment where he's
probably just getting a little bit more
social in his world and
his world is growing a little bit
learning how to use a phone probably
um and then man that he wants to call
you and see how you're doing man that's
cool
man that's awesome you know i give
anything to call my dad and see how he's
doing
you know uh so that's powerful i bet
that was a really powerful moment
you know because then now you're part of
like a friendship
now you're part of a team
you know there's just so much in that
man there's so much in people calling to
check in on
people or or when you
feel like people don't care or not and
i'm not saying your son didn't care but
when you don't know if people care
and they show you that they do
man that is so powerful
you know i've had a couple moments like
that in my life one time i had an
ex-girlfriend beautiful young lady
and i think she may have been the
prettiest girl in new orleans man i
and i don't know what she ever liked
about me but
but i was pretty lucky to bother her for
a couple years and
uh she um
and not that i wasn't kind of a neat guy
but also was not a good boyfriend
so that's why i'm saying that i'm not
speaking down on myself but
but uh anyway
she threw a surprise party for me one
time and i just didn't see it coming
you know and for somebody like me who
likes to cut you know have everything
kind of be in control and know what's
going to happen so there's no surprises
so i don't get
you know so i can manage everything man
that that was that was awesome
that was a beautiful thing like that
that that that happened
uh and then on here a couple times i've
had moments where people
just they let you know that it that that
they care and it gets through
and you feel it you know but i can
imagine that man your son
you know and in the back of your head
you're like well god i'm take you know i
take care of him and of course i love
him and he's my fan
but does he have any you know is
he ever just kind of sitting around his
job i don't know if he has a job or not
but
and you know i'm being like oh i know
what my pops up to
so that's cool man
it's cool and i think a long time ago we
used to see that people would care more
because we were in like
groups who were in tribes or whatever
you know and so you were in
smaller units you would just you see
your you know
everybody was raising everybody you were
in like these kind of smaller groups and
so you
constantly saw got affirmation that the
people
around you were supporting you
so and and thought of you as part of the
group
um and uh and there was more connection
so that's a beautiful moment man that's
cool thank you for sharing that man
that's definitely a win
uh what else we had some wild stuff that
came in
um and we got slap boxing out of pop
eyes
which is really i mean popeyes should
easily go into
a uh some sort of a ufc
you know um or ucf ultimate chicken
fighting
and it's just people straight up beating
and giving birth out there
in in the uh in the bathroom stalls
there um
but we got uh we got a couple of good
things that came in man
i'm gonna um i'm gonna rattle off these
things to you as well today
i want to let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by
super specio and kratom
now i work on a podcast called king and
the sting with brendan
and chins and they do kratom
and they seem delightful and they seem
uh
zealous full of zeal zeal
you know superspeciosa
offers only one ingredient in their
kratom and that's
pure kratom leaf it helps boost energy
relieves stress enhance mood relieve
aches and pains that's right
if maybe he was in a you know maybe a
car accident or
you know somebody was really mean to you
kratom could help if you're trying to
get into a really
tight halloween costume you don't think
you can get in there maybe
get you a couple nodules of kratom first
100 satisfaction or your money back
kratom is also used as a pre-workout
try create them and get twenty percent
off your entire order go to
get super leaf dot com slash theo
and use promo code theo for 20 off your
entire order
that's right go to get super leaf
dot com slash theo and use promo code
theo for 20
off your entire order if you're feeling
good if you want that
that that lift that excitement that
enticement
inside of you if you want the
the the the world to dangle that carrot
in front of you
that carrot is kratom
it can keep you going keep you motivated
um if you uh have struggled with
addiction you may want to check with
your sponsor first
you know and you may want to check with
yourself first and make an educated
guess
as to if this is something that uh would
affect your sobriety as well
but go to getsuperleaf.com
theo promo code theo for 20 off your
entire order
if kratom is right for you
you make your choices breaking news i
got to tell you that um
you know they're trimming everybody's
doing their trimming their drink
and getting their body trimmed up and
tightening that
that crotch and being you know everybody
wants that v-neck
that hair v-neck above their weiner
[Music]
and who can help you do that as manscape
the scariest thing you can show to some
woman isn't on kemp
penis and ass baby pna sorry butt
and weiner manscaped engineering team
has confirmed that they successfully
created
the lawnmower 4.0
okay it's a 4.0 trimmer which is now
available for purchase in the usa
and canada they sent me one i haven't
used it yet i'm very excited
i've already i've recently trimmed
myself up with deal with the 2.0 so i'm
i can't even imagine what this new thing
is going to be like i mean my penis is
going to look down four years old
the new trimmer was just released only
moments ago
joined over 2 million men worldwide
who trust manscaped with his exclusive
offer
20 off and free worldwide shipping by
going to manscaped.com
t-h-e-o that's 20 often free
worldwide shipping by going to
manscape.com
theo you know you want to you want to
put that v-neck if you don't go to the
gym at least
shave hair muscle in the air above you
above your pee and your buh-buh-buh-buh
booty you can do it it has wireless
charging new wireless charging system
uses electromagnetic induction
which can help the battery length last
longer there's nothing worse when that
thing
starts you're only halfway through
trimming your jack and it gets caught on
two hairs you're like
i'm downstairs 20
off from free worldwide shipping go to
manscape.com theo
all right let's get into a couple more
calls man we got a jordan peterson
uh impression that came in here we go
what the hell are you doing that's not
even a turn lane
and i don't see a turn signal that's not
going to work out well for you
you could be damn sure of that
that's not going to work out well for
you
that's not good let's keep going with
this guy it's like
it's like check your blind spot every
now and again maybe
how could you expect how can
how can you expect to know where you're
going if you can't even be bothered to
look in the rearview mirror at the past
you know that's that's just what i
believe
oh that's good man i gotta listen to
this part again
see a turn signal that's not going to
work out well for you
you could be damn sure of that
ah that's awesome man how how can you
all right let me try
um how can you um
let me see let me see how he does it
what the hell are you doing that's not
even a turn lane
even eternally
what the hell are you doing that's not
even a turn lane
what the hell are you no i'm missing
something
what the what the hell are you doing
that's not even a turn lane
here try a different part and i don't
see a turn signal that's not going to
work out well for you
and i don't see a turn signal that's not
going to work out well for you
what the hell are you doing and i don't
see a turn signal
that i'm not good at that this guy's
great at it though
uh and that's a tick tock right there
from that man mason
hunter with that beautiful talk thank
you nice to see that here's slap boxing
at pop pies
slap my slap box
and that's just another fight i mean
let's that is not that is people
fighting at popeyes
and i wish that you i
mean when i was young papa actually
papa's has always been a place where
at least one black person is fighting
someone
and i don't mean i'm not trying to be
racial there just that's what it is
and it's not like you know they should
have fights out front
you know i mean every year during mardi
gras we'd have to
one somebody would get murdered at the
popeyes on saint charles avenue over by
um kind of by where uh i-12 hit st
charles and r.i.p to all those people
probably 20 30 people but
um you know it's just
at this point popeyes needs to just
recognize and roll with the flow
so i would like to see that all right
let's take another couple calls it came
in here we go
hey theo my name is brandon i'm out here
in oregon that uh far far west coast you
feel me
oh yeah oregon man and um
[Music]
and oregon is uh it's a good place for
they got a lot of tree sap up there and
a lot of people playing by the rules
and not playing by the rules let's hear
more i was just listening to you talk
about uh the struggles of ego and the
sort of battles we have within ourselves
i was curious how do you find yourself
sort of getting i mean do you ever find
yourself getting sort of lost in the
character of theo
we all kind of walked around in these
masks we call identity and it's really
easy to confuse that with our true
selves
so i guess i was just kind of wondering
how do you yourself get back to that
baseline of who you really are before
ego and self-identity um i hope that
makes sense uh much love gangnam brother
gang brandon thank you man that's a good
that's a good question
you know how do we get through yeah how
do we get
you know i think we all i noticed that
who i am evolves
that's one thing i notice
and sometimes man sometimes i feel like
i was happier in a previous
skin
you know even just in the past few years
of my life i felt
a lot more connected uh to myself a few
years ago
um
you know when i don't know what happened
i mean so you know things that happened
in my life where you know my life got a
little busier with work
i made a little bit more money um
what else uh i got i started to get more
things
you know um
and so i think maybe stuff like that
like or just more access maybe
expectations um
you know and that's been tricky it's
been tough to
monitor my ego
you know i never used to really think i
had an ego and then
over the past years i've definitely feel
more like i do
and i and and it's a ego ego's just
i hate it man
you know i hate feeling like i'm better
than somebody or
because all it does is separate me
and now in some instances you need your
ego because it keeps you
safe it keeps you you know
if you can't swim your ego
might just say man we can't swim you
know and
that that could keep you living but uh
but i feel like uh and the craziest
thing is once you right when you start
to kind of live within a certain
comfortability of yourself it kind of
changes
and that's the weirdest thing about life
you know i find that once i'm right when
i'm getting a little close to myself i
i run off
you know from myself i mean i uh
i'm the one looking for myself and i'm
the one hiding
and right when i kind of get a hold of
myself and right when i'm just close
enough
to myself to just
hand myself that frisbee in that hampton
inn
spa tub
i i go underwater or i disapp you know i
or i evolve is this
i don't know more and more i realize
that this whatever the body is and all
of this
is just some shell that we're living in
you know this is just some
carrier for
the spirit that's inside of us which is
this thing that's
actually doing some evolving um
i don't know i know that doesn't answer
a lot of question but
uh and do i ever get caught up in the be
in the character myself
i used to feel like myself
and now i think the thing that's made me
feel less like myself
is work
you know it's kind of weird when your
dreams become your business
because i don't like business you know i
don't like it
it's sneaky and it's i feel like it's
i feel like it's selfish um
now that doesn't mean i'm going to stop
doing business uh
you know it's re i i i don't know if i'm
strong enough to separate myself from
the systems that we have
that you know that run this kind of like
the world that we're in
and stuff i don't i don't know if i'm
strong enough to separate myself from
them
but i used to feel a lot more like
myself a few years ago
and i'm hoping that more me comes back
around
you know i felt more angry i felt more
agitated
[Music]
which is interesting because
you know i
you would think it would be the other
way around um
but yeah i don't know i i don't
i don't know if i ever knew what was to
make me happy and i just kind of
expected that if i got
you know somewhat popular or achieved
some success
that's actually a better word is success
or what i deemed as success we all can
create our own successes
i never really chose mine i kind of just
let the world
say oh these things make you successful
you know
obtaining things or getting getting
wealthier or
getting uh popularity i never really
kind of wrote down what some of my own
successes were
my goals and stuff so i was just kind of
achieving
the status quo uh
and so i'm not shocked sometimes that
i'm left with
the status quo reality that
those things don't really make you happy
and that there's a lot more to it than
that
but i guess in some ways i'm also
grateful that there's more to it because
it still gives me somewhere to go uh
to find some peace
and i'm not saying that i'm not i don't
have peace i'm just saying
you know i want to feel i want to always
feel good if i can i know it's
impossible but i want to get close to
that
you know or always be kind of learning
about myself um
so i don't know if i'm answering some of
this question or not but i used to feel
a lot closer to myself this is the first
time my life that i've felt really
separate from myself so i think part of
me is just trying to figure out what's
making me feel that way
which is one of the reasons i've been on
somewhat of a search for that
sort of thing you know sometimes i i
think i want to
i don't know
and then also you put a lot of yourself
out there
with podcasting and comedy and sharing
and then
sometimes there's not that it's not that
there's not much
left but there's
i don't know
it's interesting man you know i remember
going to china once and
a woman didn't want me to take her
picture and she said because it captured
part of you
and that once that happened you couldn't
get that part of you back
and i wonder you know i wonder if one
day we'll see that
all this capturing of ourselves and of
each other that we're doing that it
like do deroads uh or
d d erodes us or erodes us
at some level that we don't know yet
you know i would bet there's some truth
to that
because the chinese man they
you know good and well dude they'll make
a damn soup out of anything you know and
so
they know a lot of uh ingredients
to the overall recipe i bet um
but uh thank you for the for the
question and let's get um
you know let's get we got a single mom
nomination that came in
this would be a sweet way to end out
this episode and i want to thank
everybody for being a part of this
podcast thank you to our patreon
we have a very small patreon but they
are mighty and uh
and it allows us to do fun things like
this so uh here's the nomination that
came in
oh they got a horse in it hey theo
my name's emily and i live in richmond
texas this is my horse annie
isn't she cute she's having her dinner
she's like off
um anyways i'm doing um
the single mom submission i'd like to
nominate my sister ashley
she lives in vancouver canada um that's
where i'm from originally
and she has three kids she's a single
mom
the dad kind of dropped the ball and he
does he hasn't worked in like five years
and doesn't really see them very often
so she does everything takes care of
them and
takes them to their you know sports and
everything um
and she works as a nurse uh with like
old people with like dementia and
alzheimer's and stuff which is
not an easy job so uh
yeah i think she's really deserving of
it so
that would be awesome if you could call
her and help her out um
anyways i love your podcast i listen to
it every week
and it makes me laugh so you're the best
theo all right
gang gang you know what thank you emily
so much for that
and we would love to uh to reach out to
ashley and do something and do something
sweet for them so
let's see if we can't give her a buzz
right now
hey ashley hello
hey how are you i'm good you must be my
mystery phone call today
i am is that a you have a child with you
yes yes hey what's up
um no i uh my name is theo i
uh work on a podcast you're s you have a
sister that is a horse owner
i do okay yeah well we just do a thing
on our podcast where
like listeners will submit um it's just
for single moms and so
people will submit a single mom or
somebody that they really care about
and then uh we just kind of reach out
and uh we just wanted to send you 750
bucks to go do something fun with the
kiddos
uh this summer serious yep that's crazy
that's it that's so nice well
you're welcome oh yeah your sister must
really care about you
are you guys pretty close you and your
sister well we are but
she's she's afar oh my son is there
what's up player
um we're pretty far apart and we haven't
seen each other for a while
obviously due to kovid and but yes we
are
we are close we just aren't close in
distance right now
oh i see nice well she has a nice horse
did you see that horse that she has
yeah it's annie that's annie a long time
ago
oh your daughter wrote it yeah oh dang
y'all are lucky
i would like to ride on something like
that but um
from where am i from yeah i'm from
louisiana but i live right now in
los angeles and nashville so i'm kind of
just what just trying to just be alive
really
but um so where do you work at you were
a nurse she said
i am a nurse i work in uh long-term care
in a special care dementia unit
no dementia's crazy huh yeah it's good
times
what is something about dementia that
that we wouldn't even know about
like is there anything that's kind of
interesting well
we from what i see you honestly live
in like a movie clip
that's how i can it's like you live in a
movie clip that keeps going over and
over and over again
do you understand what i mean yeah like
they're stuck in that movie clip
over and over like it could be a
five-minute movie clip
a minute movie clip or a day the next
days just relived all the same
memories that they have i don't know but
yeah it's yeah that's interesting
i hope mine is either tommy boy or um
i'm trying to think of uh what's that
other movie oh the patriot i like that
but um oh that's awesome well yeah we
just wanted to send you a nice gift just
to do something fun with the kiddos what
do your kids like to do
well oh hey what two of you are here
right now
tell them what you like to do no you
know you know what you're like yeah you
know what you want
all right you want your package to come
well
no like we what did he order we're still
on a pretty tight lockdown
up here oh wow so we really haven't been
able to do a whole lot yeah
and in the last while so like recently
we've just been doing lots of stuff at
home like
art and yeah um you know
even movie theaters aren't even open
like crazy
i know we can't do much right now um
y'all should um do y'all have any
animals
we do not have animals get one though
they want one but we don't have one i
think a bird would be good
um hey i would say i was
yeah yeah they do want a bird yeah y'all
need a good bird over there
usually the bird dies of the cat well
that's a that's a good way to
that's a very good way to state it yeah
oh that's the food chain that's the food
chain well
um well look yeah i don't know what you
guys will be able to do but hopefully
you'll be able to find something fun to
do and
um yeah your sister just obviously
thinks the world of you and so we do too
so we just want to let you know we're
thinking of you
that's amazing thank you so much you bet
and you guys come to america sometime
have your kids been to america
yeah my my mom and dad live in texas so
we did make
uh a lot of trips pre co nice
um i like canada though i like canada
yeah
we're nice people up here oh yeah canada
canada's good a lot of people really
apologizing all the time
yep it's really sweet we do
it's a really sweet place uh well thank
you for answering the phone ashley and i
hope that you have a great day over
there
yeah thank you so much thank you for
calling oh you bet
uh uh tell your kids i said bye bye
kiddos
i will get that bird get that bird
oh that's sweet man and it's really
something sweet to think about a couple
kids with a new bird you know
i think there's something
it's almost like the garden of eden or
something you know kind of like that
we had the young fella that called in
about the military and he was looking
for some suggestions
let's take a couple of those and get
some uh suggestions for the young fella
hey theo my name is patrick i'm from uh
southern oregon
i'm calling in because i that kid that
wanted to get out of the military and
didn't know exactly what he wanted to do
uh i got out of the military did the
whole college thing
hated it and then i went to uh northwest
wyman college
and uh it's for those guys that work on
all the power lines
pays really well but um just
you know keeping him in mind that
northwest we don't have any homes
to move into so if he's got a place
already
he might want to just stay in until the
housing market comes back down
okay so you could get a camper and go up
to oregon
and do the power lining and that'd be
interesting man
you know that's really that's risque
business daddy you grill your freaking
self
up apo this is aj
um best advice i give him is if you
haven't gone to school yet
go and do it get paid to go get your
degree and then do whatever the hell you
want
there you go that's another great
suggestion right there different uh
opinion here we go what's happening
my name is trevor i did
almost six years in the army calling in
to basically uh
give a little input answer for that cat
that was asking
what should he do or expect
you need to start job hunting
immediately even though you're still in
the service
you can communicate with anybody that's
specific
to what you've done in the military you
know so that way you can transfer that
flawlessly over
in the civilian world because it's a big
change homie so
there you go that's a great one yes sir
what's up this is
colin colin and i wanted to share some
ideas but i figured
most of the ideas would be like use the
gi bill go back to school go live here
because they pay
well with the living stipend um but
what i want to share is that the one
thing that i did not expect
when i got out was how difficult it
would be
to to reconnect with people
and i wouldn't expect everyone to have
as difficult
over time as i did but
um i thought i would have more people
there for me
and that's a sad thing to say but but it
also has a silver lining you just
know that and know that people are busy
and people
are struggling a lot so the people that
you might have thought you could rely on
upon getting out might not be there
well that's a good point man that like
yeah sometimes things when you went in
everybody might have been you know
finishing school and having a good time
and partying and now when you're
out uh people's lives may have changed
and
their accessibility uh to help and to be
a
daily part of your life might not be
there uh
here we go hey theo this is tyler from
out here in
l.a you know that louisville area sun
here in kentucky
oh yeah and i went to a party over there
one
time and took a felon he
robbed everybody over there and jumped
off at a rooftop here we go
anyway i'm calling some advice for the
military dude that just got out after
five long years so my advice would be
to sit down and do some serious
lifestyle architecture
right like don't rush into a job
immediately sit down really figure out
what kind of uh
life you would like to have where you'd
like to live
what kind of family situation housing
situation was going on all that
first
and then pick a career that can enable
that that you um
i guess could tolerate pretty much if
you can find something you're passionate
about even better
but uh the main thing here is picking a
job first is
ass backwards and you should really
figure it out that fits into your life
not the other way around amen um the
good thing is you have five years of
military experience and employers really
cream their pants over that so you got
that going for you
gang maybe there you go some really nice
plethora
a plethora of surrou of selections man
and uh
and thank all you guys for your service
and um and for being a part of this
podcast man i'm just
you know i'm just shocked at how many
people uh are involved in
this podcast in this group we're all
making it man
you know shout out to my buddy with that
degenerative spine disorder over there
and if uh dude if you need me to hold
you up from the back man i'll hold your
little ass up baby praise god man
we're making it man let's keep doing it
thank you guys for supporting the
podcast
uh tickets available for the tour at
theovon.com
tour thank you for the suggestions
and uh and let's go out in that same
direction man um
of absorption and that will be
with robert randolph and the family band
baptize me
[Music]
robert randolph baby
you know he's one of the greatest
that'll steal guitar players
in the universe
i'm lost in the blood
me
looking at me that way
[Music]
song
baptize me
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's that man right there robert
randolph and the family band
baptized me really fun video they have
there on youtubes and
you can absorb that and and i've heard
he's a real wonderful man too i never
met him but i've heard a lot of nice
things about that man
um anyhow
you guys be good to yourselves you
deserve it man i'm gonna try and do the
same
gang
you